der fund ist echt ziemlich mysteriös
eine antike totenstadt nicht nur eine
goldmaske sondern auch tausende statuen
und 40 stein särge hat ein
forschungsteam jetzt in ägypten
unterirdisch entdeckt eine antike
totenstadt also die wohl unfassbar
wichtige einblicke in das leben der
alten ägypter offenbar wird alles zu den
geheimnisvollen kunden jetzt endlich zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
ja wir haben ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet ergibt er hat schon jetzt
wirklich unfassbar kulturstätten zu
bieten die pyramiden von gizeh die
pharaonen stadt das grab von tutanchamun
und so weiter und so fort und es kommen
immer mehr dazu
jetzt wurde eine weitere sensationelle
entdeckung aus der hochkultur des landes
veröffentlicht 2500 jahre alt ist sowohl
die riesige totenstadt die jetzt im
ägyptischen mini entdeckt wurde
die ausgrabungen wurden schon im
vergangenen jahr in der historischen
stätte thuner algarve gestartet zitat
das ist erst der anfang einer neuen
entdeckung und ich glaube wir brauchen
mindestens fünf jahre um die arbeit an
der nekropole zu beenden sagt der
ägyptische minister kaletta lena lee ja
das forschungsteam verspricht sich durch
diese funde neue einblicke in das leben
der alten ägypter zu bekommt denn neben
dieser entdeckung die wohl aus der 26
dynastie der alten ägypter stammt seien
noch weitere funde zu erwarten nach
ihrem glauben lebten die verstorbenen
nach ihrem tod im jenseits weiter und
diese metropolen also diese toten städte
sind wirklich besonders mysteriös denn
solche ägyptischen friedhöfe sind nicht
nur einfache grabanlagen sondern
kultstätten toten städte die grad bauten
waren als eine art ewiger aufenthaltsort
gedacht glücklicherweise sind
tatsächlich viele solcher gräber der
gehobenen gesellschaftsschichten
erhalten geblieben beispielsweise
beamten oder königsgräber ein sehr
großes gräberfeld das sogenannte theben
west liegt gegenüber von nutzer das
verantwortliche ministerium in ägypten
hat bereits in den letzten monaten
einige spannende entdeckung verkündet
aber die jetzt veröffentlichten aus
grabungsergebnisse vom mini sind
wirklich ja der hammer darunter sind
beispielsweise mehrere grabkammern von
priestern die dem gott tot also tht
geschrieben zugehörig waren das ist der
gott des mondes der schrift und des
lernens charakteristisch ist sein
vogelkopf in einem der gräber wurde die
mumie des hohepriesters hsa gefunden
seine überreste sind verziert mit bronze
zudem wurden zahlreiche keramikfiguren
entdeckt 1000 davon etwa sind gut
erhalten
wenn man das so verfolgt dann ist in
ägypten noch eine menge zu entdecken und
durch moderne technologien kommen wir
immer mehr
geheimnissen auf die spur letztlich habe
ich ja hier erst über die verborgene
kammer in der cheops-pyramide berichtet
schirms pyramiden
sie war mit hilfe von millionen entdeckt
worden und ein weiteres spannendes
ausgaben projekt läuft gerade in der
grabkammer des pharaos tutanchamun im
tal der könige
1922 wurde diese grabkammer entdeckt und
jetzt sollen radarmessung feststellen ob
sich dort ein bislang unentdeckter raum
befindet denn genau diese vermutung
haben die forschungsteams es könnte
vielleicht das grab von nofretete sein
und das wäre dann wahrscheinlich eine
der spektakulärsten funde überhaupt ja
wenn er als erstes neues dazu und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video vorab eben garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion
von kriegs- und mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder mit abstimmungen bei
abstimmungen mit bestimmen die whatsapp
haben zb entschieden dass ich mir meine
haare demnächst violett färben muss zur
feier der 200 millionen dosen oder der
direkte draht zu mir ist das also
einfach draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der genau der glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch drauf klicken
ja da geht es um die geheimnisvolle neu
entdeckte kammer in der shops pyramide
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dann